à
se loger nouvellement,
maintenant.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Il y a 5 ans, Suzanne Wilson
a eu la chance de louer
ce grand 6 et demi à Val Morin.
Elle y habite avec ses 3 enfants
et paie 850 $ par mois.
Il est situé au deuxième étage
de cette maison d'allure
champêtre et à 200 mètres
de la plage municipale.
- Je me sens bien ici.
J'aime la nature, la pêche,
puis c'est pour ça que
j'ai amené icitte.
- Sauf que la famille
devra partir le 1er juillet.
La maison a été vendue
et le nouveau propriétaire
l'habitera. Suzanne,
qui a des problèmes de santé
qui l'empêchent de travailler,
reçoit l'aide sociale.
Presque chaque jour,
elle patrouille la région, de
Saint-Jérôme à Mont-Tremblant.
- Je cherche des logements,
je trouve rien. Ils sont trop
chers. Pour un 3 et demi, c'est
1200 par mois, pas chauffé.
Un 3 et demi, là. Puis...
j'ai appelé un autre, un 4 et
demi; aussitôt que j'ai dit que
j'ai 3 enfants, il m'a dit :
"Bien, c'est rien
que deux chambres."
Il m'a refusé drette là.
- Surchauffe du marché
immobilier, télétravail
et popularité de la région,
gentrification, les Laurentides
sont de moins en moins
accessibles aux résidents
plus pauvres.
Travailleuse de rue
depuis 9 ans sur le territoire,
Mélanie Bolduc aide actuellement
une vingtaine de personnes
démunies.
- Moi, j'envoie des gens dans
des chambres d'hôtels à 900 $
par mois. Fait que ça nous donne
une bonne idée que les chambres
ou les appartements sont...
pas disponibles pour eux,
vraiment pas.
- La police lui avait signalé,
ce matin-là, la présence
d'une tente dans ce boisé
le long de la 117 à Sainte-
Agathe. En plus des prix élevés
des logements, la pandémie
a incité bien des sans-abri
à quitter Montréal,
et de plus en plus
d'itinérants se retrouvent
dans les Laurentides.
- L'itinérance dans
les Laurentides, avant,
ce qu'on pouvait dire,
c'était plus de l'instabilité
résidentielle. On peut aussi
prendre le terme de... tu sais,
je n'ai plus d'emploi je vais
aller coucher chez l'un, je vais
aller coucher chez l'autre.
Là, ce que je vois,
c'est de l'itinérance vraiment
pure et dure qu'on voit.
Les gens s'installent
dans le nord. Fait que là, on
n'a vraiment pas de ressources
pour tous les accueillir
malheureusement.
- Beaucoup se retrouvent
à Sainte-Agathe, là
où ils retrouvent quelques
services, dont l'hôpital.
Pour la première fois,
la Ville a dû leur ouvrir
un refuge permanent cet hiver.
7 personnes peuvent y dormir
chaque soir et il est presque
toujours plein. Jean-Pierre
vient ici depuis 1 mois.
- J'ai couché dehors carrément
là-bas, à Sainte-Adèle.
Là, à un moment donné, un soir,
ça marchait pas, j'étais couché
à terre, je shakais puis toute.
L'humidité. J'ai été obligé
de caller les polices puis
ils m'ont emmené icitte.
- Nancy Ponton est
responsable du refuge.
Selon elle, une centaine
de ménages seront bientôt
en difficultés dans la région.
- Là, on voit vraiment
une crise. Je suis très inquiète
pour les gens qui vont se
retrouver à la rue le premier
juillet. Même s'ils prennent
la décision de trouver un loyer
trop cher pour leurs moyens,
même là, il n'en trouvent pas.
- Au cours des prochaines
semaines, le Centre de santé
et de services sociaux des
Laurentides compte ouvrir
un autre refuge à Mont-Laurier.
- Il va falloir penser
à deux postes, trouver comme
un peu dans les situations
de sinistres : des gymnases
d'écoles pour accueillir,
des camps d'été qui seront
peut-être pas utilisées cet été.
- On voit ce qui se passe
sur notre territoire
et on n'est pas habitués
à ce nouveau phénomène-là.
- Chez les élus locaux,
on sent un certain malaise
devant l'itinérance.
- Cet hiver il y en a 4-5
qui traînaient à Val Morin,
il y en a à Mont-Tremblant
aussi dépendamment des saisons.
- Là, j'entends le maire de
Sainte-Agathe, Denis Chalifoux,
dire : "Ils sont tous chez-nous
puis on peut pas s'occuper
de toute la population.
- Les maires sentent maintenant
qu'ils doivent trouver des
solutions à long terme.
- Ça prend de l'argent, d'être
en arrière de nos organismes,
de pouvoir les supporter,
offrir des locaux.
- Québec sera sollicité pour
plus d'argent, entre autres
pour la construction
de logements sociaux.
- Ça ça va être le nerf de
la guerr,e comme on peut dire,
sur les tables de concertation
j'arrête pas d'en parler.
On a des listes d'attente
de 1 puis de 2 ans pour
un logement sociaux, il y en n'a
pas dans toutes les villes.
- Suzanne affirme être sur
une liste d'attente depuis
3 ans pour une place en HLM.
Alors elle cherche et cherche
encore pour ne pas
se retrouver à la rue.
- Est-ce que ça vous fait peur
ça que ça vous arrive?
- Oui. Je veux pas que ça arrive
à mes enfants. Moi, ça me
dérange pas. Mais mes enfants...
J'ai 3 enfants puis je veux pas
qu'ils vivent ça.
- Avec le 1er juillet qui
s'en vient, son inquiétude
augmente chaque jour.
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Canada, Val-Morin.